-My first guests are
two very talented people.
He's a Super Bowl champion
and she's
a Grammy-winning artist.
Together, they're hosting
a vaccination awareness special
called "Roll Up Your Sleeves,"
which airs Sunday night
at 7:00 pm, here on NBC.
Please welcome
Russell Wilson and Ciara!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
-Hey!
-Look at you guys!
Ah!
Russell, Ciara, thank you
so much for doing our show
and coming on the show again.
I appreciate it.
You were nice enough
to come on our show
when we first started
doing it from home.
I don't know if you remember
the last interview. Do you?
-We do remember.
-We remember very vividly,
actually.
I think your daughter actually
ran in and lost a tooth.
-My daughter ran in.
She was so excited.
She's like, "Dad, Dad, Dad!"
Screaming and there was blood
all over her mouth.
[ Laughter ]
She did.
She lost a tooth
right in the middle
of our interview
and you guys were
so nice to her
and, clearly,
you're good parents.
You were like,
"Oh, how'd you lose it?"
And I'm like,
"Honey, no one else is going
to think this is cute.
Because I'm your dad, so --"
But there's just blood
gushing out and she's like,
"I lost --" And I go,
"Just get out of here."
[ Laughter ]
Go hide.
Wait 'til the interview's over.
-Anytime that happens,
it's always a good thing.
-It's a big moment.
-Isn't her name Winnie, too?
-Yes! Wait! We have --
-Yeah. Winnie, right?
-I'm burying the lede, here.
Congratulations
on your new baby! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wait.
Get ready for this.
You want to see a cute baby?
This is little Win right here.
-Aww!
-Look! Are you joking me?
[ Laughs ]
-He's the best.
-That is just precious.
Oh, my God.
The little sneakers.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
And what a great name, Win.
-Yeah, Win Wilson.
-Win Wilson.
Do you call him Winnie?
-Sometimes I do say
Winnie the Pooh.
We play off of Winnie the Pooh
with him, so, but, yeah.
-I mean, you end up making
so many nicknames for your kids.
I don't call my kids
by their names anymore.
Like I call them
Noodle and Doodle.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It's just crazy.
But how's the baby?
How is he?
-He's amazing.
-Yeah.
Win is so energetic.
He's all over the place.
I definitely think he has
dad genes all run through him.
-Really?
-He's ready to play right now.
He's ready to rock 'n' roll.
It's a lot of fun.
Our hands are tied.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You recently celebrated
an anniversary.
March 26th marks six years
to the day you two first met.
What do you remember
about that day?
-Oh, man, it was a special day,
first of all,
It was Wisconsin vs. UNC
in the lead 8, actually,
[ Laughter ]
and Wisconsin won that game.
And I was supposed to actually
go to dinner with Ari, you know,
and have a whole, you know,
dinner and everything
around 7:30.
And I had texted Ci.
I said, "Hey, can we meet up,
you know, around 10:00, 10:30?"
She said,
"Ah, well, you know, sorry.
I got to go to New York the next
morning around 4:00, 4:30."
So, you know, if it's meant
to be, it's meant to be.
I'm like, "Hold on a second.
This is meant to be."
So, next thing I know, I said,
"Hey, alright,
let's move the meeting
to 10:30."
Next thing I know,
four and a half hours later,
you know, I completely forgot
about the meeting
and I fell in love that day...
-Aww.
-...so that was one
of the best days.
-We're actually both a lot
about eating as well
because we were chatting
all night and it was special.
-Yeah, good night.
-It was meant to be.
Ciara, is this true?
One of the first dates
that Russell took you
was to the White House?
-[ Laughs ]
-Yes, that's right.
One of our first dates was
to honor the
prime minister of Japan, Abe.
And it was a special night.
It was really fun.
It was very presidential.
[ Laughs ]
But it's a good time.
It was,
yeah, really, really memorable.
-Yeah. Jimmy, anytime
you lead off with that,
I have to level up
every time, now,
so I'm trying to find new,
creative ways.
So, you got any tips,
let me know.
-How are you going to top dinner
at the White House?
Gosh!
Unbelievable.
But I heard there was
a dance party as well.
-Yes, we did.
We had a good time,
but that night
was a special night
because, you know,
we were dancing.
Prince was performing.
Stevie Wonder gets up onstage
and just an amazing night.
But the crazy thing is -- Yeah,
that's how it starts off, Jimmy.
But then, fast-forward,
end of the night, it gets late
and they got the DJ playing
and they're playing
Beyoncé's song, you know,
and they're talking about you
got to put a ring on it,
"Single Ladies,"
and Obama comes up to me
and Michelle's next to Ci
and Barack's next to me
and, next thing you know,
he's all in my face
with the ring --
♪ You better put a ring on it ♪
[ Laughter ]
And so I'm like, "Okay, well."
Now, I'm now getting challenged
by Barack Obama, you know.
The president of the
United States is telling me
I got to put a ring
on this thing, so.
-Wow!
Look at him!
Oh, my gosh!
That is unbelievable.
-Good night.
-Last time
we talked to you guys,
we talked about your foundation,
the Why Not You Foundation,
and, now, you have
a fashion house, okay?
This is called the House of LR&C
-Yes.
-and with a percentage going,
proceeds going
to your foundation.
First of all, tell me
about the House of LR&C.
What does LR&C stand for?
-Well, LR&C stands
for Love, Respect, & Care
and those are some
fundamental values
that really meant
a lot to Russ and I.
We were thinking about what
we were going to name
our fashion house.
And it's our fashion house.
It houses all of our fashion
brands that we're building out,
Good Man Brand and Human Nature,
our most recent brand
that we've launched,
and where we team up with our
good friend Christine Day,
who's a retail legend,
and she's been helping us
run this thing.
And the LR&C also stands
for Love, Russell & Ciara,
so it's a double entendre
to the name.
But it's all the values
that we're pouring
into what we're building,
and also sustainability is
at the foundation
of it all as well,
so we're really proud of it
and it's been really fun.
-It's so cool that you guys
are doing that.
I think that's awesome.
Not only that, but you're also
hosting this event Sunday,
this Sunday at 7:00 pm on NBC.
This is called
"Roll Up Your Sleeves."
How'd you get involved
with this?
-Well, our good friends at NBC
reached out to us
and, of course,
Michelle Obama asks you to be
a part of something,
you never say no.
[ Laughter ]
And so, a cool opportunity
to host a show and we want
to be a part
of raising awareness
about the vaccine,
everybody going out
and getting vaccinated.
And it also airs the day
before vaccines
are open to everyone,
which is super, super cool.
And over 806 million people
have already been
vaccinated to date,
so, you know,
we're all moving together
and we're all in this together
and so we're just raising
awareness about it.
-It's going to be fun,
just to be able to host this
and encourage people
to try to keep everybody safe.
-Yeah. Let's go.
-Yeah.
I appreciate that.
Thank you guys for doing that.